this episode of the cloud rolling update
is all about Google container builder a
scalable solution for building
containers on Google cloud platform I'm
Carter Morgan your host for this series
focused on showing off features that
make delivering software to and from
Google cloud platform a great choice for
enterprise developers in every episode
I'll show up cool technologies and tools
that I've gotten to learn from much much
smarter people like I met in Kelsey in
this case so while this episode is just
a quick overview of container builder
you're going to want to subscribe to the
playlist so you don't miss out on the
more advanced episodes and a quick aside
before we get started with GCB a
container is just a way to package and
distribute applications uniformly it
does this by logically separating an
application process from the environment
it's running inside up so inside this
boundary parts of the file system the
networking stack and other running
processes are hidden away from the
outside world to make sure that the
application is portable and behaves the
same way anywhere it's run the
application binaries also bundled
together with its dependencies and its
environment so this resulting
application container is fast to startup
and shutdown it allows you to run your
application on any system that can run
containers regardless to the type of
system that was built on and it can be
run next to other containers without
knowing that other applications are
running concurrently so aside from being
able to build an application once and
just know it's going to behave the exact
same in multiple environments the
container also simplifies application
development because two container images
can do things like both receive traffic
on their localhost port 8080 no problem
so back to container builder what
happens when you want to build a
container image a lot I like to simplify
this process by only using containers to
package and distribute my application I
don't use them to build applications so
keeping this in mind here the steps you
need to run to package and distribute
your application using docker you need a
few steps to download install docker
then you create a docker file which has
instructions on how to build the
container image then you need one or
more steps to build your application and
then a step to build and package your
application into a container which might
download a base image on your machine
just to upload the resulting image into
a registry where other people can access
it Oh
and that didn't even talk about running
an instance of your container or
cleaning up the artifacts that to build
up behind wouldn't it be great if there
is a managed service that could speed up
building and distributing your images by
skipping your workstation all together
and doing the heavy lifting in the cloud
well Google container builder is that
service you can use it with your
favorite continuous integration tools or
build systems because it uses tools you
know and love like docker files and
github so you don't have to learn new
tools to get started and on top of that
it's fast it has support for custom
build steps which can be run
concurrently and their support for using
build triggers so that you can create
images automatically and all of this all
of this comes with full integration with
Google container registered the same
service that's being used by Google
cloud functions appengine flex and more
so let's see this in action for example
if you already have a docker file you
can just use it like you normally would
to build a container image here you can
see we have a standard docker file we're
going to build our new application
container from the Alpine 3.1 base image
then we're going to add our application
binary which was built outside of docker
into our containers file system and then
we're going to run our application when
the container starts up now I can use
the G cloud container build submit
command to submit that build to
container builder from the output you
can see that we just filled a container
image without it running on our laptop
so let's explain what just happened
since we already had a docker file we
use it with the G cloud tool that comes
standard with the Google Cloud SDK to
build a docker image and submit it to
container registry Google's private
container registry all in one go now GCR
works with docker images now but other
image formats are coming in the future
it also lets you view images by name or
tag it allows you to create build
triggers that run and submit new builds
on pushes to code in your source
repository based on either your branch
name your tag once we ran that command
g-cloud packaged the source directory
and build a container image in the cloud
by executing the following steps we
compress the source directory as a
tarball
we uploaded the source package to Google
Cloud storage started a build request on
Google Cloud container builder stream
the build logs back to the users console
we'll tag the billed images and then
push those images to the GCR IO registry
and that's going to work for any source
repository directory that has a docker
file so instead of saying dr. build and
dr. push well you can just run g-cloud
container build submit so to recap
GCB is a fast and easy way to create
container images in the cloud using
google's infrastructure that just plain
works out of the box with docker files
and if you want to customize your build
process or even run parts of it
concurrently
well GCB provides a clean and modular
way to do that which we'll be talking
about in a future video so for more
information be sure to check out the
links from ahmed and kelsey in the
description below and subscribe to the
channel to learn about more advanced
features of google cloud container
builder like custom build pipelines hey
thanks for watching check out more great
videos MacLeod channels see you next
time